[Musique]
thomas bonjour alors edouard philippe 1
vient de s'exprimer devant les sénateurs
qu'est ce que l'on peut d'ores et déjà
retenir de cette prise de parole un
discours qui aura duré près d'une heure
dans lequel le premier ministre a
présenté les grandes lignes du plan de
déconfinement du gouvernement le premier
ministre qui a d'abord commencé son
discours en expliquant le confinement
avaient permis d'éviter aux personnels
soignants de devoir choisir entre les
patients mais ce confinement c'est aussi
je cite un coût humain social et
économique colossal c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement préconise un
déconfinement pas à pas avec donc les
grands axes de ce plan qui ont été
présentés par edouard philippe
d'abord les masques avec le premier ce
qui explique que le 11 mai prochain
chacun doit pouvoir se procurer un
masque il est également revenu sur la
polémique concernant d'éventuelles
stocks cachés de la grande distribution
ainsi que la doctrine à adopter dans les
écoles on écoute je les dis nous
fournirons des masques aux personnels de
l'éducation nationale et aux collégiens
pour ces derniers le masque sera
obligatoire quand il reste le de
distanciation sociale risque de ne pas
être respectés pour les élèves des
classes élémentaires le port du masque
n'est pas recommandé il est même
proscrit pour les enfants de maternelle
et j'aimerais répondre aux malentendus
qui a échauffé ce week-end quelques
esprits peut-être en mal de politiques
je dois dire que je peine à comprendre
quel intérêt aurait eu la grande
distribution a caché des stocks de
masques au lieu de les vendre en temps
de pénurie il n'y a pas et il n'y a
jamais eu de stock caché il y a des
commandes massives et il faut un certain
temps avant qu'elle se concrétise en
millions de masques disponibles pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens autres
grandes thématiques abordées par edouard
philippe lors de son discours c'est
celle des tests je cite le fer de lance
de notre stratégie voilà ce qu'a déclaré
edouard philippe qui se fixe pour
objectif
sept cent mille tests par semaine à
partir du 11 mai puis un mot a été dit
également sur l'économie avec des
efforts considérables pour les finances
publiques ce sont là encore les mots
d'edouard philippe qui a notamment
présenté deux mesures à destination
notamment des personnes les plus
précaires on écoute j'annonce
aujourd'hui également une aide pour les
jeunes précaires ou modestes de moins de
25 ans en raison du confinement les
restaurants universitaires ont fermé
beaucoup de jeunes ont perdu les emplois
dont ils ont besoin pour se nourrir et
payer leur loyer
certains jeunes se sont retrouvés dans
une situation que je c'est dramatique
nous avons donc décidé de verser une
aide de 200 euros à 800 mille d'entre
eux cette somme sera versée début juin
aux étudiants ayant perdu leur travail
ou leur stage et aux étudiants
ultramarins isolés qui n'ont pas pu
rentrer chez eux
elle sera versée mi juin aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans précaire ou le deist qui
touchent des apn le fonds de solidarité
sera prolongé jusqu'à la fin du mois de
mai il sera même renforcé pour les tpe
qui ont fait l'objet de mesures de
fermeture administrative
le deuxième étage de ce fonds qui donne
droit à une subvention pouvant aller
jusqu'à 5000 euros sera désormais
accessible à tous les commerces qui ont
été fermées y compris s'ils n'ont pas de
salarié ce qui est souvent le cas pour
un coiffeur un fleuriste d'un libraire
et dans philippe qui a également
expliqué qu'il faudra examiner d'ici la
fin du mois
la réouverture des bars des restaurants
ou encore des plages et puis on a appris
également lors de ce discours que
mayotte restera confiné et qu'une
décision sera prise d'ici dix jours
voilà donc pour ce discours d'edouard
philippe à l'heure où je vous parle sont
désormais les représentants des groupes
politiques du sénat qui ont pris la
parole et puis s'en suivra une question
une séance de questions réponses avant
donc un vote des sénateurs qui aura lieu
ce soir
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnet en direct
devant le sénat